Solange turns 30 and celebrates in style  and party is exactly what she did  over the weekend Queen B's Lil Sis  headed to New Mexico to celebrate the  big three-o with her squad and shared  plenty of pics to Instagram of her chic  soiree the birthday girl stunned in this  bold creation while her gal pals rocked  similar burgundy dresses the crew had  some fun relaxing in the pool with some  flo toys and of course enjoyed some  delicious food especially these hibiscus  lime popsicles just a great lay back  kind of chill even also there beyonce  come on you didn't think she'd miss an  epic trip like this did you  xxx so launched cheers to the next 30  being just as fabulous